[Music]
Here We Go Again Sony have officially
announced the PlayStation Plus essential
games for the month of April 2023. all
the following games will be available
from Tuesday April 4th do me a favor
leave a like if this video is useful to
you let's do this have a look at a game
coming day and date on PS plus meet your
maker from the creators of dead by
daylight the internet is calling this
Doom combined with Super Mario Maker the
Doom part is quite obvious operating as
a first person shooter making your way
through a fortress to get to the car and
retrieve resources the Mario Maker part
is how those missions are constructed as
every player who has this game creates
their own death run so to speak we are
tasked with defending our core by
building around it but there must be a
path leading to it but from there it's
completely up to us how we defend our
Fortress in previews we've seen players
build confusing mazes to frustrate other
players we've seen high-skilled ninja
warrior style courses built we've seen
super sneaky hidden traps everywhere to
take out visiting players and of course
we can defend our base with a legion of
grotesque minions constantly ready for
battle so while you are away attacking
another player's construction someone is
attempting to beat yours you're either
building or raiding in meteor maker and
it's available on both consoles PS4 and
PS5 I love this concept I hope it does
well will you try it Sac boy a big
adventure is next for April a 3D
platformer from the release of the PS5
but it's also on PS4 too this isn't like
the Little Big Planet games of old where
creation is key this is a straight up
Super Mario inspired Adventure a linear
campaign taking down the evil Vex the
handcrafted world is set up like an
interactive diorama in which we find
regular upgrades to break through to new
biomes such as a grappling hook and a
crazy addictive Boomerang some Sackboy
levels are put together with amazing
soundtracks both new tunes and chart
hits like hearing Bruno know Mars crank
out some Uptown Funk as you progress
through a mission you can't help but
smile and then all the enemies and
inanimate objects on stage perfectly
move in sync with the music which is
directed by your own actions completing
each stage isn't very troubling but the
real way to finish each one is to
collect all the mcguffins in the level
Never Dying once and picking up a
perfect gold medal which allows for
stronger players to aim higher even when
playing alongside a less skilled player
Owen with four player co-op possible it
quickly becomes a free-for-all to win
the stage and the photo opportunity at
the end reviewers have Sackboy a big
adventure at about 7.5 out of 10. really
fun with a friend and finally this month
is Tales of iron a hack and slash RPG
with an amazing art style which may
dissuade you from playing but scratch
that surface and you'll find a brutal
combat system with inspiration from
Souls games just a little bit more
watered down the story has two warring
kingdoms of frogs and rats and they must
face off and as the heir to the rat
Throne you must back on a perilous quest
to reclaim your kingdom it's got an
interesting story helped Along by
numerous side quests and hunts for
blueprints but I think it really comes
down to if you enjoy 2D fighting games
review scores range from Perfect 10s to
more realistic sevens I'm on the fence
with this one how about you Tales of
iron is again for both the PS4 and PS5
so that's our month what you're thinking
happy sad frustrated glad please do me a
favor and throw a comment below I'm Adam
you're awesome it's been a pleasure see
ya
[Music]
thank you